we close up shop here with the great Al
Michaels who will call Super Bowl 52 on
NBC first of all thank you for what you
did for the opening our Super Bowl
opening have you seen this I have not
okay if we can if dawn is in our truck
she can roll this just so you can see
your cameo appearance in the opening of
our Super Bowl coverage
what happened was we made it seem like
we're ice fishing right and I would have
seen ya they showed me that when I did
yes I did my part and then I would put
like Paulie loves Walter Payton I put
Walter Payton's Jersey on a hook and
then put it down there and pulled him up
McLovin with the jersey for him and then
for you I put a Sports Emmy on my hook
and then put it down in the in the hole
and then all of a sudden I pull up
mm-hmm Al Michaels look how clean you
are you got you get your sport coat on
you're looking good you got the Emmy and
then you walk off and that's it right
there that's well done well done quite
the actor take 37 how long did it take
for you to shoot that 22 minutes and 14
that I like that I did promise you 30
minutes or less I think Paulie did 30
minutes or less he lived up to it
whatever he said a lot of fun stand for
you anything thank you well thank you
thank you well how much prep work do you
do this week leading up to the game
you know our prep work is like all year
long it's not you don't know who's gonna
be in the Super Bowl we knew obviously
that it was our year we just stay
abreast of the league it's not as if you
really over prepare for this because we
prepare like crazy for every Sunday
night game you know we have Fred Goodell
is our producer so he leaves no stone
unturned and we're armed to the teeth
for every Sunday night game we treat
every son that I came like a mini Super
Bowl you know so I'm not saying you can
over prepare for this game but we've had
these teams three times each this year
Philadelphia three times from I think
late November on so we know the teams we
know the stories what you really do is
you go back over your notes and things
that you might want to talk about but
they and the whole key to do in the game
is let the game begin let the game start
and let the game take you to where the
game is because we'll go in there with
18 gazillion stories but most of them
are gonna wind up as they say in
television or in the movies on the
cutting room floor people don't want to
hear about things that are not germane
to the game so that's the key well
sometimes you're trying to force an
element into the game right and whether
it's consciously or subconsciously and
the audience can almost feel that like
what's this have to do hey I got this
great story we're getting this great
story in the game no question about that
I mean I've always said it through my
career I look at the game the game is a
melody we're providing the lyrics so if
you have a beautiful melody in the
lyrics or off-center it's cacophonous so
you want you want the lyrics to blend
with the melody and you know the great
thing work with Chris now for ninety
years Michelle as well and we've got a
you know obviously a fantastic crew we
know where to go with this stuff it's
like you don't go far astray some of the
greatest stories I've ever had and that
have not been told was stuff we just
couldn't jam in you don't want to do
that you don't want to you know jam that
square peg into a round hole I was
mentioning this story about the call
that you had this Seattle New England
Super Bowl and that to know that that's
Malcolm Butler who's knifing in to make
the interception and I believe there was
a play two plays prior where Malcolm
Butler was some Malcom Butler might have
been in the back of your mind or at
least his number attached to his name
and that helped you in the immediacy of
that call no question about it the other
thing too is that the way that he makes
the play from where our booth is I can
see his number two it's not as if he
comes in from the other side where if
you have a you know a jam job in there
you don't know so you know you say it
and then within maybe a tenth of a
second I look down at you know Kelly
Hayes is my spotter and he's got the
finger on Butler so that's one of those
moments where you know yo you just pray
you're right because if you're wrong
they just play it back for
stays you never live it down over and
over and over and over to explain your
spotter though how close they are to you
and if somebody makes a play he's
pointing to their number or their a name
yeah that's part of what Kelly doesn't
Kelly's been with me for almost my whole
career we go back to college football in
the late seventies and George Hill my
statisticians so I mean I've had the
same people who are fantastic it's not
only identifying people but it's also if
somebody comes into the game or comes
out of the game or somebody gets hurt
there are a lot of things that Kelly
would do to draw get my attention drawn
to it because you can't see everything
at once but he's kind of watching I mean
somebody limps off the field you might
miss it he's got it that sort of thing
so he's invaluable we have a whole crew
I mean we've all worked together for so
many years it's hand in glove it really
is
you've been vocal about replay that it's
not called instant replay anymore it's
called replay right and also what's a
catch so it feels like you've you're fed
up now like I can hear it in your voice
where you're audible in saying oh yeah
some shocker you know when they go down
and here's the call in the field I think
I speak for the fans in that regard you
do the fans hate this thing
who wants a four and a half minute
review we had one of those in the Falcon
Ram wild-card game where you could see
that the punt touched the RAM player and
then Atlanta recovers it but there was a
two-minute discussion on the field and
then at the end of that discussion it
hockey Lee said we're reviewing the play
wait a minute they've just reviewed it
for two minutes so we go to a commercial
there's another two and a half minutes
and we come back and we what are they
looking at here this is so obvious and
then it came back on on the mic and you
know said what the what the situation
was which we had been saying for four
minutes and I couldn't resist I said no
kidding so they've got to figure out a
way to set the speed I think they will -
this is getting out of hand but the
commissioners not even sure what a catch
is I mean white why they're gonna end a
Super Bowl I'm telling you if they're
not careful you're gonna have a crazy
fetty's gonna come down and now there's
gonna be a 25-minute delay to get the
confetti off the field least the calls
gonna be overturned
that's the worst scenario but you had
Brady last year how awkward is it that
youth not sure if it's an official
touchdown to win the Superbowl and Brady
is saying hey hold off hold off you know
Matt Ryan's there to congratulate him
he's like hold off I don't even know if
this is a touchdown correct so we're not
getting that spontaneity of you jump won
the Super Bowl no and they're trying to
make it as I say what if they would have
said no white didn't get into the
endzone the other thing is in the Stefon
Diggs catch here you know a couple of
weeks ago against New Orleans clearly
he's in bounds I mean an unbelievable
play where you know the the tackle is
missed but digs has the president's to -
it's the same bands you see a couple of
replays took them two or three minutes
to confirm that oh yeah like why what
what in the world were you possibly
looking at and we heard that you know
they wanted to get a bunch of eyes on or
whatever the hell that means I don't
know what that means but I mean there's
there was no question it's gonna take
away it just takes away from from the
game itself no playing it you can't have
these four or five minute delays you
can't
well what would do you believe in
miracles have been now I mean it's do
you believe in miracles we're not sure
and that's gone hold on right well we'll
be back in four minutes we'll be back
yeah don't have the same ring to it now
yeah the great thing is our sales
department could probably sell that spot
for five million or thirty so they'd be
pretty happy about that you believe in
miracles
[Music]
yes back after these messages we'll come
back we'll close up shop here final 15
minutes with Al Michaels we'll be back
after this in the Dan Patrick show
[Music]
I was still with us we appreciate that
and as we get ready for Super Bowl 50 -
do you get nervous describe your
emotions when right before that kickoff
you can't wait for DES story it's a long
day we'll be there for you know probably
four hours before the game so you know
you keep looking at the clock and I want
it to be I think it's five o'clock local
time that we come on for the pregame
show yeah there's a certain amount of
anxiousness I think more than
nervousness like let's get it started
when's the last time you were nervous
probably last week no I know and I it's
it's not a nervousness so much as it is
an anxiousness yeah let's go
you know what the countdown to story
let's let's make it happen
you try not to make yourself nervous
probably like the players you know you
can feel it there are butterflies but
let's get going and once you get going
you've been there before I think I've
done pretty close to 700 professional
football games so like the players say
once they take that you know first hit
okay they're in the game so you know
Chris and I whack each other in the ribs
and away we go
how many Super Bowls this is ten best
one I would say 43 Arizona Pittsburgh it
had two unbelievable plays iconic plays
James Harrison 100-yard interception
return Santoni homes his catch Arizona
what are they doing there Larry
Fitzgerald is having a postseason for
the ages they almost won the game 49
would be New England against Seattle the
Butler interception at the end of the
game but I've done you know I did the
st. Louis Tennessee game where Dyson
gets stopped at the one-yard line at the
end or would misses the field goal in
Super Bowl 25 that would be another one
and we had Giants against the Patriots
back in 11 people forget that game ended
with Brady launching one of the endzone
Gronkowski is there otherwise that game
is with kind of a miracle finish so have
you had a blowout I've had three
them yes a denver against washington and
87 which was ten I think Denver at the
end of the quarter
first quarter and then thirty five ten
Washington Doug Williams had a
phenomenal day that was a blowout San
Francisco San Diego and 94 49ers won 249
to 26 and they were favored by like 18
Steve Young Steve Young six touchdown
passes and then Tampa Bay against
Oakland and Oh to where Jon Gruden had
taken over for Tony Tony Dungy
and and they won the game in Sandy at
the game tried to get close but couldn't
so five have gone down at the end I've
had three that are routes one which was
the game in Detroit no five which was
Pittsburgh in Seattle which kept
bordering on being good so I'm hitting
fun if I'm a baseball player I made four
five you're doing well 556 yeah going
that and that's all you want before the
game begins you just say thank you let's
let's get a great game you know John
Madden used to say to me before we did
three Super Bowls together give me a
little fist bump each say let's go ahead
and make a memory and part of making
that memory is the game is good McLovin
final results of our poll question
brought you by man versus food on Travel
Channel whose career would you want if
today's gas Drew Brees JJ Watt Eli
Manning by far the winner Al Michaels
yeah you made the poll question today
really yes whose career was you like
yeah you had 48% of the vote drew brees
it's 22% of the vote I don't have to get
sacked would you rather have your career
or do breezes I'm not gonna give up my
career friend are you kidding me I'm
I've been blessed
now breezes had a fantastic what about
Brady I'll take mine I don't get hit I
would take your career yeah absolutely
yeah we'd all take your career but take
your life I mean I wouldn't take your
life I would like to have your life we
have that on the record
McLovin what did you learn today
Rutledge would question juniors
athleticism yes he did really yes he did
Rutledge wood is nasty man he stabs
people in the back or junior fritzy what
did you learn you expect Tom Brady will
throw at least 50 times on Sunday yes I
do see no Connor Eli Manning can dunk
yeah there you used to be able used to
be yeah Paulie would you learn I didn't
learn it but I know it Al Michaels will
be eating steak tonight
Alex great scene probably thank you for
standing by as always for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]